[Música]
en el corazón de parís en el barrio de
montmartre el moulin rouge destaca desde
hace más de 120 años
y cabaret más célebre del mundo donde el
espíritu provocador de sus inicios se
mezcla con una exigencia de excelencia
[Música]
su solista más conocida llegó hace 10
años de kazajistán cada mañana corre
media hora para permanecer al más alto
nivel
si hay que mantenerse siempre en el
mundo siempre hay casting chicas nuevas
cada vez más jóvenes siempre hay que
estar en forma se tiene miedo de ser
reemplazado sí pero nos corresponde a
nosotros hacerlo todo para no ser
reemplazados para las 60 bailarines de
14 nacionalidades diferentes los
criterios de selección son muy estrictos
1,75 metros mínimo cualquier desviación
en el peso de más de 2 kilos está
prohibida creo que somos más deportistas
de alto rendimiento así seamos bailar
ellos sí por supuesto es el ritmo que
hay que tener muy importante de este
sacrificio no se arrepiente ninguna de
las bailarinas porque bailar en el
moulin rouge es inscribirse en la
historia de un lugar mítico donde las
mujeres tienen un lugar especial
la historia de dos siglos de
emancipación felina donde desde el siglo
19 las primeras bailarinas lograron una
proeza
ganan más que los hombres gracias a
figuras de las que tienen el secreto
este nuevo baile el cancán afecta a la
autoridad y las reglas establecidas
ahora las mujeres están autorizadas a
moverse sin ser guiadas por una pareja
de baile su representante más célebre es
la gurú no es un canon de belleza pero
baila como un ángel
a principios del siglo 20 el agua se
vuelve un lugar turístico inevitable
además de las mejores bailarinas ahora
hay que lucir los vestidos más bellos
una tradición que no ha cambiado
tuvo que haber un pequeño problema
bailando el cancán y hay que conocerlo
en nuevo imperativamente puede ser otras
cosas brillo y lentejuelas cada
espectáculo requiere mil vestidos por un
monto de 4 millones de euros algunos
hacen parte de los más costosos del
mundo y ello se debe a las plumas
provenientes de criaderos de avestruces
y de paisajes caen naturalmente de la de
antes de ser limpiadas peinadas y
podadas es lo que se denomina los pique
soleil es lo que se le aplica el vestido
desde la rueda hasta las extremidades
del vestido
son las 8 y 50 y para olga el
espectáculo está por comenzar
todo está listo nos metemos en el
vestido y regresamos al escenario no hay
tiempo para pensar se tiene miedo cinco
minutos antes de ingresar al escenario
si incluso un poco antes miedo sí es
importante es bueno las nueve horas del
espectáculo
tras bambalinas se cuenta cada segundo
para olga quien debe cambiar de vestido
con cuánto tiempo cuenta para vestirse
dos minutos es rápido de hecho nada debe
caer en el escenario debe sostenerse
todos los años de los 400 asalariados
del moulin acogen a más de 600 mil
espectadores momento clave del
espectáculo el célebre french cancan
y es otra vez olga quien entra en escena
cuenta con un minuto para conquistar la
sala
[Música]
se trata del baile más físico del
programa cerca de 4 kilos de ropa botas
a la medida y articulaciones que sufren
[Aplausos]
el momento cúspide del espectáculo se
acerca olga debe enfrentarse a las otras
estrellas de la velada cuatro pitones de
varios metros cada una un número para el
que se postuló como voluntaria
[Música]
y siempre le reconozco que no es
evidente sobre todo cuando se acerca y
entonces se tiene la impresión de que
van a hacer algo pero como están más o
menos acostumbradas a los seres humanos
todo sale bien
tras dos horas en el escenario los
artistas saludan al público la velada ha
terminado y olga puede salirse
satisfecha de su personaje
[Aplausos]
y todo salió muy bien pero cansada estoy
contenta sí de irme a dormir descansar
un poco siempre es agradable es un buen
cansancio buenas noches
bani
cuando olga regresa a casa el moulin
guardián de la plaza blanca sigue
titilando para hacer vibrar los
corazones nocturnos de montmartre
durante toda la noche